depuis le 1er janvier 2023 il y a une
loi qui oblige tous les restaurants d'au
moins 20 place assise à supprimer les
emballages à usage unique et à les
remplacer par de la vaisselle
réutilisable alors j'ai voulu savoir si
c'était effectivement le cas et je suis
allé dans plusieurs grandes enseignes de
fast food voilà ce que j'ai vu
il y a aucun
gobelet du jetable carton
bon là je sors du McDo et il y avait
aucune message réutilisable ni pour les
burgers ni pour les boissons ni pour les
frites donc là pour le coup ils ont pas
trop appliqués la loi mon deuxième façon
pareil pas du tout de vaisselle
réutilisable que oui en carton papier
merci
[Applaudissements]
là je suis au Starbucks et j'ai une
tasse en céramique et pas un gobelet en
carton
vert comme ça ah oui c'est ça bon du
coup j'ai contacté ces enseignes pour en
savoir plus et seul McDonald's m'a
répondu voici leur réponse plus de 90%
de nos restaurants se conformes à
l'obligation légale depuis le 1er
janvier soit plus de 1300 restaurants
nous sommes au travail pour les 10% de
restaurants concernés afin de proposer
ce service dans les meilleures délais
c'est quelques restaurants rencontrent
des difficultés au niveau local pour à
titre d'exemple mettre en œuvre le
service de plonge attente d'accord des
propriétaires de locaux délai de permis
de construire manque de place etc cela
concerne aujourd'hui principalement des
restaurants de centre-ville ou de centre
commerciaux j'ai contacté une
association qui est justement en train
de mener une enquête complète sur la
mise en pratique de cette loi ce qu'on
constate
[Musique]
de façon approfondie c'est qu'on a pas
mal d'enseignes une bonne partie où
c'est toujours de l'usage unique comme
on va complètement ce que nous on a pu
constater aujourd'hui donc un constat
qui reste assez mitigé c'est à dire que
on trouve pas trop trop dans le sel donc
c'est vraiment 100% respecté et puis on
en trouve surtout pas du tout c'est une
mesure qui a été votée à l'automne 2019
en novembre à peu près et la loi elle a
été promulguée le 10 février 2020
que risque les restaurants ne se
conformant pas à cette loi il y a une
demande qui est prévue en cas de
contrôle et de constat de respect de la
loi les restaurants peuvent payer
jusqu'à 7500 € d'amende qui monte à
15000 en cas de récidive après l'état
français histoire de la transition
écologique à au moment décidé de laisser
un peu de temps aux acteurs mais ils ont
annoncé que d'ici quelques mois elle
commencerait les contrôles pour
justement les vérifier
ou non de la loi il y a la vaisselle qui
entre en compte dans ce genre de
restaurant et finalement est-ce que la
consommation d'eau ça vaut le
remplacement de ces déchets c'est
souvent la question qu'on se pose mais
finalement est-ce que c'est plus
intéressant d'aller sur quelque chose
qui va être certes utilisable et qu'on
va devoir à laver ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que quand on produit quelque chose
qui a les États-Unis qu'on a aussi la
consommation d'eau lorsqu'on veut dans
le meilleur des cas recycler ce qui a
été ce projet usage unique parce que
justement on l'a utilisé l'activité il
faut consommer le dossier pour le
recycler quels sont les problèmes
rencontrés par les restaurants pour
passer à la vaisselle réutilisable mais
entièrement à 100%
problème que les restaurants c'est
vraiment l'entraînement d'un changement
paradigme des enseignes comme McDonald's
Burger King kfco qu'elles ont vraiment
construit leur business autour de
l'usage unique donc là on leur demande
vraiment de changer leur pratique c'est
tout plein de mécaniques à changer et
surtout des choses assez opérationnels
logistique il faut prévoir un espace
pour pouvoir collecter la vaisselle
qu'on va laver il s'agit plus seulement
d'ajouter dans une problème mais
vraiment bien récupéré en bon état il
faut un espace pour pouvoir la laver un
espace pour pouvoir la sécher et puis
qu'elle attendent avant de pouvoir être
réutiliser donc là on a un problématique
de place on a une problématique de
formation des équipes qui n'ont pas été
habitués à ces gestes qui doivent aussi
faire évoluer leur pratique et puis
aussi une problématique de comment on
fait prendre ce geste consommateur et
consommatrices par exemple chez McDo
c'est du plastique est-ce que finalement
on prend pas plus de risques à ce que se
plastique se retrouve dans la nature là
effectivement la loi n'a pas précisé ce
qu'on attendait des enseignes en leur
disant de passer donc là les en
Starbucks sont partis sur de la
céramique et du vert de façon très très
décisionnelle nous on espère que les
enseignants se sont bien posé la
question parce qu'au-delà du coût d'une
matériau pour elle la question qui se
pose c'est est-ce que vraiment le
matériau choisi peut effectivement être
utilisé un grand nombre de fois est-ce
que c'est un matériau qui emprunte peut
être bien pété ou pas est-ce que c'est
un matériau qui présente pas de risque
pour la santé etc etc
[Musique]